[Music]
anita is with us in pensacola to start
off this hour
hi anita how are you hi i'm fine thank
you very much
good how can i help uh well here's
here's
the little rundown on it uh my husband
and i are
65 and we hope to retire in about five
years we're
we're planning to work until 70 or if
one of us should get disabled and we
would retire then
but we are out of debt we have our
emergency fund
and 15 is going into retirement
right now good we're at a point that we
were thinking
uh to go ahead and start paying off the
house
good but here's the thing
since we only have about five years to
go
and i i don't know i haven't looked at
the at the figures just
in the last little while uh last year
when we met with the smart buster pro we
had a little bit less than a hundred
thousand i mean 200 000
in retirement but that was just as we
were starting the 15
so at this point we don't know we have a
like i said we have a small mortgage and
it's at 4.875
in other words four and seven eight um
so we're trying to determine whether we
should just
start putting all that extra into
retirement or
paying off the house uh you should put
15
of your income away and everything else
you can find in your budget you used to
pay off your small mortgage what's your
household income
uh about 75 000 between the two of you
right okay and how much is the mortgage
balance
the mortgage balance is about 63
okay all right and so
uh if we really lean on this mortgage
because it's an emergency
because it kind of is uh if you
if you paid you said 63 000 right
right you make 75. so 31
where 32 would pay a year would pay it
off in two years
21 would pay it off in three years
okay so sounds like two thousand dollars
a month on the mortgage
while you're putting at least fifteen
percent away now that puts you
three years that puts you three years
later your house is paid off
because here's the thing okay you need
both going into retirement and
let me walk you through why you need a
paid for house and a nest egg
because a paid for a house is your your
housing is your most expensive line item
in your budget
if you don't have it paid for if it's re
if you're renting it goes up every year
while you
try to live from 70 to 90 over 20 years
your rent's gonna go through the roof
so number one you own number two you get
it paid
off and then you gotten rid of
the biggest item on your budget your
house payment
okay okay so you've stabilized your
golden years
by getting the house paid off and then
of course we need this stuff like
food and electricity and gas for the car
and that means we need to have money
coming in from retirement which is the
nest egg side
and so right you know but i think you're
going to be fine here here's let's run
some numbers out
let's say you did 21 000 a year or you
did 2 000
a month you can do that you're just
going to get on a tight budget and watch
what you're doing because this is
important
that sounds tough it's very tight it's
very tight tighter than you've ever
lived on
i know that because you don't have any
money much and you're 65.
no so it's time for you time for you to
tighten the screws up it's
college i i know but here we are today
it's time for you
you you got to do this now there can't
be any more reasons there can't be more
reasons you got to do it
so two thousand dollars a month put you
out of debt in
under three years slightly under three
years
okay okay and now the 200 000 you said
was two years ago
uh well about a year and a half ago okay
if you didn't add anything to that and
you will be
that 200 000 will double about every
seven years
if your mutual funds are earning around
10 or more
and they should be okay so
200 is going to be 400 when you're 70.
okay because there's two years ago seven
years to 70 right
right so that's 400 plus you're going to
be putting in
another thousand dollars a month which
is twelve thousand dollars a year which
is fifteen percent of your income
into retirement and you've already been
doing that so you've already got a
little more
and you're gonna be doing that for the
entire five years oh wait
no you're gonna be doing that only for
under three years
and then there's no house payment so now
you can go to two thousand dollars a
month going into nest egg
oh okay and two thousand dollars a month
twenty four thousand a year
plus twelve thousand a year for three
years show you maybe
there's another hundred fifty thousand
bucks plus what it grows
okay so by seventy by seventy you should
have
six seven hundred thousand bucks in a
paid for house if you do exactly what i
told you
but if you go screwing around and keep
messing with this and coming up with
excuses you're gonna have a mess so you
need to act like your hair is on fire
for the next three years
two thousand dollars a month plus a
thousand dollars a month into retirement
that's three thousand dollars a month by
the way three thousand dollars as much
36
000 out of seventy five thousand that
leaves you that leaves you enough to
live on
okay but you ain't living large you're
living small
no no so we never have lived large yeah
so that you can have some golden years
from 70 and on right
okay yeah this is this is within your
reach
the math says you can do it now
personal finance is 80 behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge
we just gave you the 20 head knowledge
now you got to go do the behaviors
which is by the way is the hard part i
mean the math of becoming wealthy is not
heart it's sixth grade math
but nobody does it so hey good question
thank you for joining us
here's what's interesting if your mutual
funds average 12
which the stock market has averaged a
little over 11 and a half since it began
so if your mutual fund slightly
outperformed the market and you made 12
and you put a hundred dollars a month
away from age 25 to age 65
100
pizza breath you spend that on pizza
one hundred dollars a month
every month from age twenty-five to
sixty-five is one million one hundred
seventy-six thousand dollars
everyone in america should retire a
millionaire
if you grasp that knowledge oh wait
you have to do the behavior oh there's
the problem
the idiot in my mirror is a problem
child
if i could get this guy to behave he'd
be skinny and rich
but he's got issues the behavior people
it's the behavior it's not the math the
math is not hard
we make enough money in this country to
be wealthy
but it's controlling our little selves
me too baby that's the problem